or all of the above we'll bring you
takes from all sides no matter how far
apart over the next 60 minutes
all he's interested in doing is blaming
everyone else
can't he hear the country screaming at
him gets on with your job
the reason his authority is on the line
in this matter is that they take
they take 10 million pounds from the
unions mr speaker
pretty punchy at prime minister's
questions today and as inflation hits a
new high rishi soon act says the
government is doing what it can to help
those who need it
now i want people to be reassured that
we have all the tools we need and the
determination
to reduce inflation and bring it back
down
uh the chancellor there we'll also have
some top guests on the program tonight
including the deputy secretary general
of the national education union neve
sweeney we'll also talk to labour's
shadow immigration minister stephen
kinnick
and we'll also be talking to the mp dean
russell about his anti-bullying campaign
plus we'll have lots more besides all
coming up on the take
[Music]
hello good evening with inflation
hitting 9.1 it's no wonder that people
want a pay rise tomorrow rail workers
will walk out for the second time
causing major disruption and they're not
the only ones threatening industrial
action with teachers also balloting for
strikes but as the government and the
unions lock horns whose side is the
public on we'll be trying to find out on
the programme tonight so let's crack
straight on we're going to start with
the best bits of the week so far
the dead hand of this tory government is
all over this dispute
and the fingerprints of grant shaps and
the dna of rishi sunac
are all over
the problems on the railway both sets of
proposals are unacceptable and it's now
confirmed that the strike action that is
planned for this week will go ahead good
morning the biggest walkout of rail
staff in over three decades is underway
with millions of commuters facing severe
disruption it's totally unfair the
average train driver earns 59 000 pounds
the average rail worker earns 44 000 the
average nurse 31 000
they do not get a bad deal we need i'm
afraid everybody and i say this to the
to the country as a whole and we need to
get ready to to stay the course grant
traps can come to the table if he wants
i'm not particularly bothered but if he
wants to come to the table he'd be
welcome as long as he comes in a
framework of goodwill what he needs to
do really is allow the management of the
train operating companies and network
rail the license to get on with
negotiating i don't drive so
as a zero hour contract basically if i
don't work i don't get paid so every
time they go on strike i end up losing
money the end goal is to get better pay
in better conditions and if this is what
we have to do and and i support the
workers then then that's what has to be
done if he's genuine about preventing
strikes will the prime minister tell
this house how many meetings he or his
transport secretary have had with rail
workers this week to actually stop the
strikes it is a disgrace when we are
planning to make sure that you don't
have ticket offices that sell fewer than
one ticket every hour mr speaker but he
yesterday had 25
labour mps
out on the picket line and the shadow
deputy leader out on the picket line mr
speaker backing the strikers mr speaker
while we back the strivers
[Applause]
[Music]
well it feels like it's a wedge issue
for the government or at least they hope
it is but i do wonder how this is all
going down with the uh public and sam
coats our deputy political editor
is
with us
it does feel doesn't it as if you know
both the government and the unions are
very happy to kind of lock horns with
each other but where would you say that
public opinion is it's really
fascinating you say that um sophie
because if you go and talk to mps in
private uh on the conservative side
actually
they see some political upside
despite all of the misery that so many
people are experiencing they think that
by being able to paint the labor party
as of course traditionally the workers
party uh with historic links to the
trade unions as being on the side of
these strikes and that's not really
technically true if you listen to
kirsten but they want to paint their
puzzles being on the side of these
strikes then there are electoral games
that might convince voters that you
can't trust the economy key questions uh
with kirsten but the interesting
question sophie's is that really true
and just how unpopular are these strikes
now actually this week yougov have done
some polling it'd be quite interesting
to look at some of the
results that we've got and the first
question that we asked was uh do you
support the rail strikes at all now more
people oppose the strikes than support
them that's clear 45 opposed 37
support but that figure is just a little
bit high more than a third of the
population uh support those strikes and
i think that shows that there is just
some residual sympathy for demands for a
pay rise at a point where inflation
today according to the ons is nine
percent i guess if people feel in their
pockets that they need to pay hours
themselves and they have sympathy with
other people potentially asking for one
too and he's a surprising result she's
going to the next round we compared the
result to just two weeks ago and you can
see actually
support for the strikes has gone up
despite the fact this poll being taken
on the day of the first strike and those
who oppose the strikes have gone down
and that's really interesting because it
suggests that as cost of living in uh
issues come up as people try to work out
uh what they think about the strikes it
isn't a slam dunk as some tory mps were
suggesting to me last night that this
will automatically be a bad thing uh for
the labour party good thing for the
conservatives and that um everybody is
revolt uh revolting against the strikes
uh that unfortunately will be going
ahead again tomorrow and i guess if the
conservatives aren't trying to use this
as a wedge issue if you like and then
what really matters is where do their
swing voters stand where do their own
supporters stand is there any
inclination about that yes absolutely
and so here's one of the most
interesting things about the politics of
uh the strikes if we look at the number
of people who say that they were
affected by this week's fight so if you
had a little look at this um we have
here have you been impacted your travel
plans been impacted this week just 18
say yes 76 percent say no that's a very
so less than one in five of the
population actually saying that they had
a direct negative effect as a result of
the strikes now there have been
wall-to-wall coverage on sky news and
elsewhere all the papers have been
filled with stories about strikes but
it's not necessarily uh affecting as
many people as perhaps the coverage
might indicate then look at who amongst
the country
is particularly affected if we look at
the regional breakdown here
and it will show us
that london is the most affected uh now
london typically a labor city lots of
commuting lots of rail use lots of tubes
tube strike uh and disrupt sorry
separate to the rail strike that we've
been experiencing
this week but
london and scotland are the two places
that are most affected but in the areas
that likely to determine a general
election uh the rest of the south only
15 percent effect that's less than the
national average the midlands and wales
15 the north 15 those areas
actually what you find sophie is the
people who are affected by these strikes
are
in urban areas they're often men
younger men who rely on train journeys
but that just isn't as many people
perhaps as
some of the coverage some of the hopes
of tory strategists
might uh
might rely on because i think that
strikes are a difficult issue for so
many but there is real concern that a
time of nine percent inflation clearly
pay rises nothing like that in the
public and the private sector uh that
the public see this issue as being more
complicated perhaps i find it utterly
fascinating and it does feel like in
this time then all of our sort of
preconceptions about how these things
will go go down we need to be quite
alive to movement or being challenged in
that as well sam thanks very much we'll
have more from sam
as we go on the programme as well now
they're really interesting as well of
course is we've been focusing of course
on the rail strikes
so far
but it does feel as if the strikes could
spread to other industries too big news
for parents and pupils because teaching
unions have said that they will strike
in the autumn unless their pay better
matches inflation the national education
union has written to the education
secretary nadine zahawi to say that
they'll campaign in favor of industrial
action unless the government recommends
what they describe as an inflation plus
pay rise
we can speak now to the deputy secretary
general of the national education union
neve sweeney thank you so much for being
on the program
do you feel like a teacher's strike is
inevitable
i think it's more likely than it's been
in my 20 years of of working in the
profession uh if you know even before
the pandemic teachers were working more
unpaid over time than any other
profession and when early career
teachers calculate their hourly pay
they're often being paid under the
living wage as a graduate profession the
pay simply hasn't kept up with with
other uh graduate professions and
teachers are saying to us
that they are finding it difficult to
get to the end of the month their
heating bills and their fuel bills mean
that they are struggling to survive
uh yeah i mean look look i think don't
think anyone would uh say that times are
easy particularly of course people
who've had you know years of pay
restraint
i'm just interested to know exactly what
you're calling for so you say you want
an inflation plus pay rise inflation of
course is currently at 9.1 percent
what is the pay rise that you want to
see
well at the moment we think that the
strb is likely to recommend to the
secretary of state about a three three
percent pay increase now
with cpi or rpi that means an actual pay
cut for our members of between six and
eight percent and
of austerity and pay restraint and last
year's pay freeze so the average teacher
will have lost between 70 and 17 and 20
in real terms of their wages so if they
don't offer something that is more than
at least cpi inflation the majority of
teachers will be facing another year of
a pay cut
so let's just be really really clear
then on what you're calling for uh
inflation's currently at 9.1 percent so
so what it just spell it out for us and
what is it that you want to see
we've said to nadim
today that he needs to
very seriously consider an above
inflation pay rise for teachers across
the board and it needs to be fully
funded
so we need to make sure that schools are
able to pay this because what we're
seeing is a teacher recruitment and
retention crisis one in four teachers
leaves the profession within two years
and one in three teachers leaves within
five and that means that children and
young people are less likely
you want to see pay rise with over 9.1
that's correct is it we have to make
sure that teachers aren't having another
year of a pay cut and that's what
they've been suffering for the last 10
years plus the pay freeze that was
issued last year to all of you what
exactly are you calling for
so we we have said that we're calling
for an above
above inflation pay pay fully funded pay
rise for all teachers and all education
workers we mustn't forget that support
staff uh you know support staff wages
have not kept up with those of retail or
hospitality and support staff members in
our schools work with some of our most
vulnerable children and those with
special educational needs and disability
if the government doesn't address
teacher pay then it is going to face an
even bigger workforce crisis than it is
in at the moment and what we are seeing
is children in secondary school having
three or four maths teachers within a
year i've got a friend who's a physics
teacher who started after easter and
every time he comes to the end of a
lesson the children say to him sir are
you coming back next week children need
a qualified experienced teacher who is
committed to the profession that isn't
worried about whether they can pay their
mortgage that doesn't you know isn't
worried about whether they can fill
their car with petrol at the end of the
month and isn't facing 2 000 pound hike
in their own child care fees you know
we're a profession of 76 women who have
suffered through austerity and have
suffered through the through the
pandemic there's a pay gap in a pension
gap and children and families and
schools deserve better
okay um so pretty clear then that you're
going to be balancing a fraction you
want to see an above inflation payroll
say reading between the lines of what
you said that's effectively double
figures above 9.1 percent
so my other question is you know
children have lost so much education
time already because of the pandemic and
we know that it's the most deprived
children who've suffered because of that
you know according to the sudden trust
social mobility fell by 12
thanks to the lost learning uh during
during the pandemic
how comfortable are you that if teachers
do go on strike that's going to be more
lost hours for children in the classroom
and more disruption particularly you
know for those underprivileged children
teachers are acutely aware of the impact
that them taking strike action would
have on children that's why they would
never take it lightly and that's why you
know it's taken this crisis for for them
to be considering it but i've spoken to
more teachers this week who have said
that they would for the first time in
their career consider taking strike
action because they recognize that it's
not just about the pay in their pockets
it's about recruiting graduate teachers
into the profession and keeping teachers
in the profession so that children have
a well-qualified experienced teacher
teaching teaching them
we've seen you're right the children who
are most deprived you know it's often
the fact that they are coming from uh
families that the educational
disadvantage is already in place before
they reach school so if the government
is really really you know true to its
word about leveling up it will invest in
early years education and invest in
fully funded pay increase that keeps
teachers in the classroom
okay um i've spoken to mitt lynch of the
rmt at the weekend who said that they're
effectively prepared to keep striking
until they get what they are asking for
when it comes to pay
i just wonder if that's the same for
teachers how long could the strikes last
for
well we haven't had a a pay offer from
the employer yet so we are hoping that
the department of education that is in
tsar we would read our letter today
we'll hear the news stories and all the
interviews of teachers that i've heard
on the news and regulations how long the
question is sorry to just to try and you
know
re get back to the question but the
question is how long could the strikes
last for
well we haven't even balloted yet sophie
so that's why we're putting this warning
out this is the strength of the feeling
and the crisis of the cost of living
that we are in right now we have said
that we we are committed from our
conference in uh easter to run an
indicative ballot in the autumn term and
we will be recommending to our members
that they vote yes for strike action
that's a warning stand i understand that
we're early in the process but i know
that
i know that you know parents will be
i know that parents will be like really
concerned about the idea of staff going
on strike even though of course many i
guess would understand the desire for
better pay you know were we talking days
are we talking weeks are we talking
months or do we just not know
that will be down to our members and
what they decide they are willing and
prepared to do
but i tell you what parents are also
concerned about parents are concerned
that teacher vacancies are up by 14
teachers are parents are concerned that
their children are their class sizes are
rising because classes are having to be
merged because teacher vacancies aren't
being filled and parents are concerned
that their children are being taught by
non-subject specialists we're finding it
more difficult to recruit i.t teachers
teachers that need to develop curriculum
that's vital for our economy and vital
for young people entering into the
workforce and the next phases phases of
their educational career that's what
teachers our parents are are extremely
worried about and nadim sahabi needs to
hear that call and needs to ensure that
uh teacher pay maintains its its balance
with other graduate professions and that
we are getting the
right number of teachers to come into
the profession and keeping teachers once
they get there
okay thank you very much indeed for
coming on the program and explaining
your position to us that was neem
sweeney of the national education union
well it certainly feels uh that it could
be not just the rail workers who are
striking from that interview it
certainly feels as though uh perhaps is
an inevitability that teachers will uh
too so i'm quite interested now to try
and get more of a sense about how people
are feeling about the strikes we can
talk to our regular uh panel of uh
viewers on the programme we talk to
people from across the uk across the
political spectrum as well
hello everyone good to see you all here
today and i'm interested to get your
views on the strikes of course as well
let's start off with uh tom horne shall
we on the rail strikes i think we should
start off with now tom you're 19 you're
at university uh you have been one of
the 18 that sam coats was talking about
earlier where your plans have been
disrupted by the rail strikes what's
happened
yes yes so i was meant to be going home
from uni this week
but because of the strike that's not
possible because i go to union leeds
and i live in cornwall and all trains to
cornwall
have been cancelled past the same point
and obviously there's just general
disruption
so i've not been able to do that
so i had to go last week and for a
shorter amount of time and
at very short notice which um kind of
recap with my work and the job
but um yeah i managed to get home at the
end but
well i'm glad that you are a lot of
different planning i'm glad that you did
manage to get home your audio was a
little bit wobbly for us there uh tom so
um i will try and come back to you later
if you view on the strike but it did
feel got the gist of what you were
saying uh you know that you had to
change your travel plans back home
because of the uh strikes today um so
let's uh let's talk uh should we uh to
belinda shall we um belinda campbell
you're you're twickenham you're a swing
boat you describe yourself as uh don't
you
now you're again someone who has been
quite impacted by what's happening the
railways and you told our producer that
you're self-employed but you've actually
started turning down work because you
effectively just don't trust the
transport system
yeah and i've um since the pandemic i've
decided to try and work from home as
much as possible and there are
opportunities out there i mean in the
pandemic i think the government should
have provided opportunities for people
to work at home but um i would rather
not travel on the trains and
and overcrowded expensive trains i do
understand why people strike because
it's a powerful mechanism
um
and but it has such a knock-on effect
the bigger picture is you know it sends
like shock waves through the economy and
affects so many people um such a range
of people
so i i know
they feel that's the only choice they
have but i think there has to be some
consideration in there too
um
but it's a very powerful message and so
i i understand i think the public do
understand as well why people strike
it's interesting it feels like you're a
little bit split on it effectively um
understanding some of why people strike
but at the same time feeling you know
the disruption of it as well uh let's
talk uh to uh vic daniels shall we let's
bring in vic daniels at this point
because i feel like you've got a bit of
a different
uh take on this perhaps um you are
someone who you're quite critical of the
strikes and talk to me about how you
feel about the railway strikes
well i mean i've got nothing personal
against mike lynch or the um uh the rmt
um but i just don't think they they
should be allowed to hold the country to
ransom um uh i think it's only the
prison workers and the police who are
legally um prevented from striking and i
personally believe that that list needs
to be extended
and is that because of the disruption
that it causes people or the impact on
the economy
yeah i mean you know looking at sky news
this morning there was some stuff on
there about um a social care worker that
wasn't able to get in uh to look after
the elderly uh we've been heard stories
about students who haven't been able to
make it into their exams um uh we've
people that have had long covered delays
in terms of appointments are also
finding that they've had to cancel their
interviews
and probably won't get rescheduled for
several months um i i just don't think
this is right and i don't think that one
union or one set of professionals should
be able to as i say hold the country to
ransom it's wrong
i'm quite keen to broaden the
discussion out a little bit now to your
education because i know that the
rest of you have you know some views on
this whether you're working in the
education profession or you've got kids
at school uh let's bring in uh rob shall
we rob tyler and now rob you're a
conservative voter you're from bolton
but you have got experience in the
education profession i'm interested to
know your view on whether you've got
sympathy with teachers who are
considering strike action
well um i actually take issue with what
leave sweeney said then she talks about
pay gaps and pension gaps but um
teachers that are working for further
education colleges most people don't
know this and i imagine most mainstream
education teachers not nervous but
further education college teachers that
do exactly the same job as six farm
college teachers teaching air levels and
vtec get paid thousands per year less
than their colleagues doing exactly the
same job
and to be honest it's it's actually
ridiculous um
the uh the education secretary um put
forward a three percent uh paid
suggestion and the aoc uh met with the
union recently the neu recently
and the neu asked for a 10 pair rise and
they've been offered an improved offer
of 2.5 percent
so if the mainstream gets the three
percent just three percent they'll still
get more than the uh fe teachers will
get and why that your peer gap even
further and that's you isn't it you're a
science teacher you're a science teacher
aren't you so that impacts you doesn't
it
it does indeed yes absolutely
yeah interesting stuff really
interesting well let's talk to
lisa goddard now shall we at least
you're a university lecturer you you've
trained teachers up uh so you've got a
bit of a feel about how uh they're where
they're about i guess when it comes to
strikes and what's your view do you
think strikes in the education um
profession are effectively inevitable
now
just go back to our previous person who
spoke and he's right that further
education and higher education get paid
less than
teachers not trying to uh
not trying to move away from the
teacher's point there because
uh so if you remind me of your question
again do i think that they will strike
do you think they're yeah do you think
it's inevitable do you think that they
will strike
uh
it's been a long time in education
without pay rises because of inflation
uh and austerity and pay freeze
and
i can see why teachers need it now i
know teachers are going to food banks
things are really difficult in the
education system but but teachers
teachers love the job they care about
the kids it will be really difficult for
them to strike and also you have to
remember that when you can't afford
when you can't afford things as it is
going on strike actually
is is it's difficult financially for
teachers to go and drag
because
you lose pay you would only go on strike
if there's an absolute last
resort and and maybe actually the
country is getting there and maybe we
will get we will see the strikes it's
really interesting uh well great to talk
to uh two uh people in the education uh
profession let's talk to a parent now
shall we hannah walker you're a labor
voter you're from dorset you've got a 12
year old son so obviously
if teachers walk out that's going to
impact you as a parent would you support
teacher strikes
absolutely um i think any
any workforce has the right to withdraw
its labor if it needs to to to get a
decent pay rise and i think the point
about further and higher education staff
is that they should
their wages should rise we have a lot of
people on very low wages we have high
employment but a lot of people on low
wages they should be paid more but that
doesn't mean that teachers shouldn't get
what they deserve it just illustrates
exactly that we have high energy we have
high employment rather and people aren't
being paid enough to to shelter these
costs of inflation
petrol costs everything else it
it points to a bigger problem there i
think than just
certain sectors there are lots of people
who have very low paid jobs who should
be paid more yeah that's the point isn't
it i guess so the fact that you know
there are lots of people who
particularly at time of high in
inflation are going to be asking for a
pay rise um i know that some of you are
probably quite tall on this so feel free
to not put your hand up if you are but
just raise your hand if you're generally
supportive of the strikes
one two hands going up there and if
you're generally against the strikes put
your hands up
one
two
there you go well it's a bit split isn't
it interesting stuff thank you so much
for uh coming on and giving your view
interesting to really try and sort of
drill into some of that public opinion
on uh strikes you're watching the take
we are live right here in westminster up
next we're gonna have the latest on some
calls for the snp's westminster leader
in blackfoot to resign over his handling
of a sexual harassment allegation
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
i'm lisa dowd and i'm sky's midlands
correspondent and this is where i grew
up
we can reveal that the driver who hit
harry dunn is 42 year old and sakulas
just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far
this is what they're up against that the
wind is the really big problems it is
back-breaking work and the smoke is
thick
[Music]
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary we're terrified
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
[Music]
i never knew they would make it it's
amazing
change seems tantalisingly close in this
corner of the uk wales was the first to
introduce the plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take now there's
been some growing criticism of the s ps
westminster leader in blackfoot over how
he handled a sexual harassment
allegation against another mp our
political correspondent liz bates has
been looking into the story uh for us
and liz just give us a background to
what happened
uh well first of all sophie this dates
back to something that took place
in 2016 a party that was attended by a
very young member of snp staff he was at
that party subjected to some unwanted
sexual advances
from an snp mp patrick grady
now fast forward a few years he took
that to the independent parliament's
independent complaints process
that was upheld patrick grady apologized
he was suspended for two days since that
happened a lot more has emerged around
this uh story and the spotlight has
really turned to how the smp deal with
these types of allegations and in
particular their leader ian blackford
and that's really for two reasons first
of all uh a leaked recording of a
meeting with ian blackford and his mps
emerged in which he encouraged those mps
to um to really rally round and show
support not for the victim but for the
perpetrator patrick grady the other
issue is his approach to this incident
when he first heard about it so what we
understand from the staff member
is that at the time he was called into
ian blackford's office um he wasn't
aware of what that meeting was going to
be about in that meeting he was
confronted with patrick grady now he
believes now that was entirely
inappropriate i was speaking to that
staff member on an anonymous basis and i
think we should hear from him
when i walked into his office i've got
ian blackford the leader of my party
that i work for and i've got the chief
whip of the party i work for and also my
line manager crying in front of me
apologizing
um i i i was made to feel guilty in that
situation i felt bad for him in that
situation looking back i know that's
irrational now
but at the time um you know i felt like
i had no choice but to accept the
apology and to be honest i was scared
at the time that it would affect my
career
um and honestly since with what's coming
out since then um i was right to fear
that because it's exactly what's
happened
there have been calls in the in
after
what's happened to you has emerged and
we've seen
uh the failures at different stages
for ian blackford
to resign is that how you feel
yes i think you know ian's position
right now is unterrible and it will
continue to be so the longer this goes
on it will only get worse
so you see the victim telling you that
he thinks that in blackfood's position
is in untenable have we heard anything
from in blackfoot on this well we've
heard a little bit from ian blackford he
hasn't made a a public statement on
camera he doesn't want to come and be
interviewed but we have had a written
statement from him in which he's
apologized for what happened he's also
said that there'll be an external review
of uh the snp's processors for dealing
with this suggesting that there'll be a
big overhaul
many uh opposition uh mps as you can
imagine have been very critical of him
some suggesting that even
calling into question his future and we
spoke earlier today to labour's uh ian
murray who is the shadow scotland
secretary and this is what he said
ian blackford's apology or non-apology
yesterday was essentially victim blaming
if we want to try and find a way of
changing the culture within politics
within westminster and the wider society
then those in leadership positions have
to take the responsibility and i think
he really should consider his position
there's been a lot of discussion hasn't
there in westminster about culture uh
and about how these allegations are
dealt with i know it's something you
personally have been looking into as
well
do you think there is a cultural problem
and is any change happening well i have
to say i mean you you've been around in
westminster quite a long time as well
you know this is something that we talk
about every now and then it comes up and
there's big promises about you know that
things will change and that culture will
really be uh addressed but i mean you
only have to look to the next couple of
days we've got two two by-elections
coming up the reason that those two mps
have stood down first of all in
wakefield that mp uh was found guilty of
sexually assaulting a teenager in
tibetan and hunterton uh the mp stood
down because he was caught watching porn
in the house of commons so we do now
have this independent complaints process
it was brought in a few years ago
clearly it's not entirely stamping out
what is going on here and i think there
needs to be
much more done if we're ever going to
address this problem of culture yeah i
think you're right aren't you that it
does seem to just come around
periodically
and there's lots of strong words but
then when it comes to action
no one can really agree anything uh liz
thank you so much uh really important
story to bring you uh this evening
you are watching the take we are live
right here in westminster up next we're
gonna hear our question of the week
where we give a backbencher a chance to
respond to the prime minister
[Music]
[Music]
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the board
hello welcome back live to westminster
you are watching the take let's take a
look now to look at prime minister's
questions kirsten has been on pretty
punchy form recently today was no
different as the two leaders clashed at
the despatch box uh we can have a look
now at pmq's unwrapped with our own
political correspondent ali fortescue
a day until the long-awaited bar
elections in wakefield in yorkshire and
tibetan and hunterton in devon it was a
rowdy pmq's with both kierstarma and
boris johnson keen to get in their
pre-election pitch
he's crashed the economy he's put
everybody's tax up the last tory sent up
to wakefield being convicted of a sexual
assault that's not much of a pitch prime
minister people of this country and the
people of wakefield people of tibetan
and hollister would much rather vote uh
for a solid conservative government
for a labor party they're enablers and
acolytes in the liberal democrats mr
speaker the chameleons the
before the pitch though came the punchy
first question from labour's chris
elmore about claims carrie johnson was
offered a top job in the foreign office
prime minister have has he ever
considered the appointment
of his current spouse
to a government post or to any
organization yes in one of the royal
households i know why the
uh the party opposite wants to talk
about uh non-existent jobs uh in the in
the media mr speaker because they don't
want to talk about what's going on in
the real world
last week the labour leader was
criticized for avoiding big divisive
issues like the rail strikes this week
he engaged when the pm accused labour of
backing the strikes
the prime minister of this country and
his transport secretary haven't attended
a single meeting held a conversation or
lifted a finger to stop these strikes
the reason his authority is on the line
in this matter is that they take
they take 10 million pounds from the
unions he's standing with the strikers
mr speaker and lifting the cost of
transport for everybody that's the
reality
kirstarm's questions this week were
focused on the economy and strikes our
analysis of his language shows that the
word he used most was pay he also used
words like wakefield bankers people cut
government
the prime minister used words like
pounds country and railways boris
johnson knows the strikes are tricky
ground for labour and there was a
notable absence behind the speaker's
chair today yesterday labor whip nav
mishra disobeyed kierstama's order that
his front bench shouldn't join the
picket line today he was missing from
his usual spot the key is genuine
meanwhile on the tory benches plenty of
cheering and pointing unity on the
subject of industrial action and from
the great government critic the smpz and
blackford a muted appearance thank you
mr speaker can i associate myself can i
associate myself with the remarks of the
prime minister
his first pmq's since apologizing for
backing a colleague suspended for sexual
misconduct the prime minister though was
kina any opportunity to steer onto rail
strikes when is he going to stop
meaningless sound bites and instead
start supporting working people across
our country
if she if she wants to support the
working people of this country mr
speaker can i suggest she gets off the
picket line
a sum of strikes could mean political
pain for labour but widespread commuter
misery isn't good for the government
either for now though all eyes are on
two very different long-awaited bar
elections tomorrow
ali fought as you there now we have a
regular slot on the programme to talk to
a backbencher
and we pick our pmq of the week the one
that caught our eye during the session
earlier let's have a look at today's one
sadly bullying can have a long-lasting
effect on mental health and well-being
so today the diana award are raising
awareness about bullying in schools and
online and with the don't face it alone
campaign so will the prime minister
please join me in encouraging any young
person experiencing bullying to speak up
and speak out
kai thank you very much and uh uh
congratulate him on on his
own campaign on this issue i think
everybody understands the bullying is an
absolutely appalling experience and
something that we should not tolerate in
our society and i'm delighted to see so
many colleagues so many honourable
members uh wearing uh their blue ribbons
today mr speaker we should all speak out
against bullying but we should also make
sure that we give everybody the courage
and to speak out against bullying as
well
now of course usually the question
doesn't get the chance to respond to the
pm's answer but we're trying to put that
right so today
we can talk to the conservative mp for
watford dean russell who put my question
to the prime minister thank you for
being with us um you i can see you're
sporting your blue ribbon an enormous
amount of mps were doing the same at
pmq's today and what did you make of
what the prime minister said to him
well it's great to have number 10 and
the prime minister's backing of this
fantastic campaign you know the the
campaign itself is in over about two and
a half thousand schools i believe 1.5
million young people are taking part in
uk youth charity the diner rewards
activities and in particular around the
don't face it alone campaign so the
opportunity to have the backing of
number 10 they did an event i believe on
monday which featured people like rio
ferdinand talking about their
experiences and their work with young
people but also the opportunity to raise
awareness and i i very much appreciate
you having me uh on tonight to to tell
people that you know don't face it
alone.com if you go there you can get
lots of free resources schools teachers
parents lesson plans videos and really
it's about raising awareness and i was
so fortunate that mr speaker chose me as
a very last question to come in right at
the end
and share awareness of this fantastic
campaign
it's been i've been really struck with
some of the interviews that i've done
recently and also some of the stories
that have been shared on social media by
some pretty high profile mps about their
own experiences of bullying and i know
it can be quite a difficult thing to
talk about because it's one of those
things that people tend to kind of bury
quite deeply inside because it's very
painful uh you know i spoke to nadim
zahawi the education secretary he was
talking about being chased around a park
and dunked under water in the pond by
bullies brandon lewis the northern
ireland secretary uh tweeting today
saying that he was bullied as a teenager
he's dyslexic he was overweight he was
seen as an easy target older kids
thought i was too stupid to succeed too
fat to be taken seriously
you know how important is it do you
think that people in these positions are
open about some of the difficulties that
they faced when they were younger
i think it's incredibly important and
it's great to see colleagues be so open
about it i mean i've been campaigning on
mental health and mental well-being for
quite a while now and i was fortunate in
the session to promote the initiative in
watford that i do to train a thousand
mental health first aiders with some
fantastic organizations including the
watford and west arts chamber of
commerce who helped deliver that with
volunteers and the key theme on it all
is sharing one's experiences learning
from others talking about it and not
being afraid um to share that because i
think the challenge we've seen in
society is there is a stigma and there
has always been a stigma sadly around
mental health and in particular around
bullying and i think actually what this
campaign's trying to do is get people to
talk about it to don't face it alone as
it's called and as the uh as the the
main phrase of it but actually what it's
about is to speak out but also to speak
up and if you're seeing bullying in the
school or your friends and someone's uh
struggling because of it you know
support them speak up about it and let
people know because
invariably
when i've ever i've spoken to children
about this in young people when they do
make that move actually it totally
removes the bully's power
and actually the power that the bullies
often have is to keep people silenced
and keep them you know so in their
control and actually that's where you
can speak up and and diminish
really important thank you so much
coming on a really important interview
uh to give thank you
thank you
now kierstama has been treading a
careful line on the strikes he hasn't
condemned them he also has told a labour
mp not to show support by appearing on
picket lines not necessarily the most
successful in doing that well we spoke
today to the shadow immigration minister
stephen kinnick who was on the program
today i started by asking him if he
backed the strikes
what we need to do is keep focused on
the government because it is the
government's job to make these talks
work it's actually in the contract
between train operators and the
government that industrial action
should only take place at the direction
of the government and the decisions the
operators make should be at the
direction of the secretary of state for
transport but boris johnson and grant
schapps have been completely absent from
these talks and from this process and
that's because they want these strikes
to happen so i think our job as labour
mps as the parliamentary labour party is
to stay focused on the government to
make it clear that it's the government's
job to get people around the table and
that i think has to be the singular
focus of what we're saying and doing in
parliament it's it's pretty clear um
that that's the kind of line from labour
i guess what i'm still struggling to
understand is labour's actual position
on the strikes i'll rephrase it if you
are an rmt member would you be voting
for action
yes i would be because i think that um
the
there is the right to strike and it's
really important that workforces have
that right to strike we believe that
uh rail workers health workers people
working in every industry that has done
so much as well to keep our economy
going through the pandemic have the
right to strike and to fight for a
better deal and what was really
incredible today was to learn that the
government is looking to lift the cap on
bankers bonuses so whilst they're
preaching uh to those who've kept our
economy going through the pandemic that
they have to exercise wage restraint
they are telling the bankers uh that
it's all right to just carry on raking
it in it's breathtaking hypocrisy and i
think what we really saw today is where
the government's priorities lie um
we believe in uh working people getting
a good deal in terms of pay terms and
conditions a strike is a last resort for
getting that but sometimes that's what
you have to do well i've been listening
to you it sounds like you you do agree
with uh you know their right to strike
you know your pro worker that if you're
an rmt uh member you would vote to
strike that people deserve to you know
get paid
at the level that they should be um
do you think that case thomas must judge
it a bit then because actually if you
look at the polling you know there is
more support for the strikes and perhaps
some would expect 37 support than
according to yougov do you think he's
misjudged the public mood
i think he's got it absolutely right
actually because he has said very
clearly that his job and the job of
labour mps and the parliamentary party
is to keep the focus on the government
oh come on he hasn't he hasn't been back
he's been very he failed he's been very
careful uh not about the strikes to tell
labour and peace they shouldn't be
joining picket lines and to effectively
you know
move away from the debate we need to
keep our fire on the conservative
government and the way in which they
have failed uh to get the strikes off
the get the talks off the ground to stop
these strikes from happening and the
reason is because they want the strikes
to happen kier i think has called that
out really effectively and i think the
way he's done that has really cut
through with the british people okay um
so you're saying that you want the
government to get involved to get around
the negotiating table so what would
labour do then uh the rmt wants to see a
pay rise of seven percent to uh
effectively match uh inflation last year
when they were being negotiated um
would you agree to a seven percent pay
rise
it's not our job as labour mps to tell
the rmt what is a deal that they would
accept and i wouldn't ask you to i'm
asking if you were in government you are
asking the government to get involved if
you were in government would you accept
a seven percent pay rise it's also not
the job of government to publicly say
what the outcome of negotiation should
be those negotiations have to take place
around a table where there's trust
between all of the uh key parties are
you happy with the seven percent pay
rise though do you think that's the
right ballpark
well the rmt has to be very clear on
what its bottom line is uh and to be
able to take a deal back to its
workforce that can be approved and it's
for the workforce to know they are the
hard-working
uh
people in our rail industry that have
kept our economy going through the
public they can't say no better
they know better than we do uh what is
the best deal for them and what works
for them okay and teaching unions are
also a balloting for strike action we've
heard from the unions there that they
want in their words an inflation busting
pay rise 11.7
currently the offer is 3
would you agree to an 11.7 rise for
teachers what we've seen is people
taking a real terms pay cut and
inflation of course plays a role in that
but what i would first of all say is
should those bankers be having their the
cap lifted on their boat
who are making over half a million
pounds a year let's have some
in the salaries let's have some leveling
up and some justice in the way in which
our economy works like we know that you
would like to see the cap on bantis
bonuses we know that you think that the
chief executive network is paid too much
11.7 for teachers is that fair
i think we have to have a deal for the
teaching unions to take back to their
members that they would find acceptable
specifically in the public sector would
you like to see pay rises for the public
sector matching inflation
i want to see the public sector getting
a fair deal and that is something they
have not had for many many years we've
had 12 years of tory austerity
12 years of public sector pay freezes
and that has led us to a situation where
the workforce is demotivated demoralized
they pulled out all the stops to get our
country through the pandemic and they
deserve some justice and they deserve
some fair play and i think that's not
that much to ask so the government has
to be ready to come forward with a
policy on pay that is going to work for
public sector workers but they also need
to have policies to grow our economy
what's labor's policy on pay then well
we're not in government so we don't we
we need to
see the government engaging with the
public sector but we've been clear that
public sector pay freezes were not the
right way to go and we've been clear all
the way through that public the public
sector pay should be in line with
inflation now of course we're seeing
inflation uh going through the roof
and so we are going to have to have a
compromise which is based on giving
people the fairest possible deal that we
can get in difficult economic
circumstances but we also need to see
the government taking action to get
inflation down that means getting a much
better deal in terms of trading with the
european union than we currently have
because the price of imports are going
through the roof it means taking v80 off
energy bills it means growing the
economy investing in
productive sectors like wind farms and
insulating people's homes so you
actually create good jobs driving up
productivity that's the only way to
really deal with inflation in the long
term and have much more sustainable
growth so the government has to do these
two things a fair deal for our workers
combined with pro-growth and
pro-sustainability policies
another busy show that is it for the
take we'll be back next week and every
week on wednesday at 9pm next up sky
news at 10.
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent
half time of my life on the on the sea
we have a factory who can convert this
plastic to energy and so after at the
end we can minimize the footprint carbon
of the boat